what do you think Gustus would say if he
knew that his story had touched people
all around the world both in a book and
now as a film well that's actually a
really interesting question I think
because you know because because
Augustus is obsessed with being
remembered and all he wants to do is you
know be remembered and leave his mark in
the world however at the end of the
story
he learns that it's not that important
and that he's okay with just being loved
deeply and not widely so hopefully
Augustus wouldn't give in to the
pressure and would be like you know what
this is nice but I am more grateful for
hazel than all this attention for my
story
so it's obviously done amazingly well in
the u.s. we expected to do well over
here as well but some of the money they
made in the u.s. is from you and
Shailene going to see it your cell was
incognito I said how was it watching
yourself on the screen and in such a big
audience as well it was great you know
because you you sense we're seeing me
with an audience
there's the crying is very present and
that is pretty amazing because the other
three times had seen it I've seen it the
loans were just with one other person or
a few of
so this is you could really hear the
crying and the laughter and the
screaming when we came on screen and it
was amazing the energy it's fun it's fun
to watch theater it's like you know
theatre with an audience obviously but
even movies is a sense it's a form of
theater and you should watch it with an
audience
definitely so what was the most
challenging scene firstly to film and
then also to watch back as well in an
audience maybe the car scene I
definitely cried a bunch while I watched
that but I think that the actually the
toughest things were just like the the
long back-and-forth scenes with me and
Shailene because your it was more that I
was just judging myself acting so much
that I couldn't like it took the first
couple watches of the film to get over
the fact that okay that's me acting I
understand I just stopped judging myself
and just watch the movie from a
third-person perspective and the third
and fourth time I was able to do that so
that was great it's just funny then why
do you think this story is connected
with people so much and why do you think
it's such an important story to tell
well yeah I think it's a big question
but there's a lot of reasons I I think
one reason that young people connect to
it so much is because it's a young
person's story that doesn't undermine
young people and it says that yes even
though you're young you can still leave
and you're young you can still do things
that are meaningful and even if you die
young you can still leave live a
meaningful life also for for sick people
even if you're sick you can still leave
live a meaningful life and if you die
early of cancer your life is not any
less meaningful than anyone elses I
think that's an important message to put
out there because a lot of the times
Hollywood makes movies that are about
healthy person people like learning
lessons from sick people for a change
this is a story about two sick people
and and yeah it's that's that's good
you